you have a metal arm
with everything going on in the mcu
sometimes there are stories we don't get
to see
bucky's passed as the winter soldier and
his recovery from hydra's brainwashing
may have been glazed over in infinity
war but we're finally going to shed some
light on those mysteries
from winter soldier to white wolf we'll
walk you through bucky's transformation
including what marvel didn't show you in
the movies
what the hell from brooklyn to the
battlefield
bucky barnes has always been by steve
rogers side
i thought you were dead i thought you
were smaller
so how did cap's best friend end up
working for hydra
it all began in world war ii when part
of the 107
infantry regiment was taken prisoner by
hydra it was here that arnim zola
subjected barnes to experiments to
recreate erskine's super soldier serum
cat finds bucky strapped to a table
dazed and mumbling his name
and serial number to himself indicating
that zola may have already been trying
to break his mind
fortunately he's quickly snapped out of
this stupor when he's rescued
he's even able to recognize steve
despite all of the changes his skinny
little buddy from brooklyn went
through these experiments allowed him to
survive the fall and the loss of his
left arm during his final mission as a
howling commando
he ended up in zola's clutches once
again who was likely already working for
hydra within shield due to his
recruitment through project paperclip
the procedure has already started
the winter soldier then spent the next
70 years being brainwashed and tortured
his memory was periodically wiped and
obedience was programmed into his mind
with a series of code words to activate
him
he was sent to carry out numerous
assassinations for hydra
being kept in cryostasis between
missions it's obvious that hydra had put
a lot of effort into
keeping bucky under their control they
wiped his memory in the short time
between the attempt on nick fury's life
and the fight on the bridge and again
before he's sent to stop cap on the
helicarrier
the saddest part is bucky's reaction to
hearing he has to endure another memory
wipe
you can see the fear written all over
his face but he doesn't try to fight it
he's been conditioned not to resist
hydra's orders in their efforts to strip
him
of free will mission report now
despite seven decades of being hydra's
puppet it all begins to unravel when
steve rogers simply calls him by his
childhood nickname
lucky who the hell is bucky previously
cold and calculated
you can see the cracks starting to form
in the winter soldiers control
he freezes clearly struggling to process
his own thoughts as memories begin to
come back to the surface
alexander pierce has bucky's mind wiped
before sending him back into the field
for his final confrontation
with captain america but steve goes all
out to save his best friend
he steals his original world war ii
uniform from a museum
hoping it will jog bucky's memories
steve spends their entire fight trying
to remind bucky who he really is
he even stops fighting back as soon as
he's sure that hydra's plan has been
stopped and the world is no longer in
danger
angry confused and afraid the winter
soldier tries to deny
everything steve has told him and
frantically tries to carry out his
orders
to eliminate captain america he at last
breaks when steve tells him
because him with you to the end of the
line
repeating what bucky once said to steve
all those years ago
after his mother's funeral horror and
realization
wash over bucky's face as he finally
sees the truth
he was about to kill his best friend
defying his order
bucky saves steve from the potomac river
after the helicarrier crash
dragging him safely to shore and leaving
without saying
a word he goes into hiding living in
romania and staying under the radar
according to sebastian stan bucky's
backpack in captain america civil war
is full of notebooks he writes down all
of his memories as they come back to him
out of fear that he may forget them
again bucky now deals with an intense
amount of guilt
over his actions as the winter soldier
although he was not in control of his
own mind
he feels grief and shame for all the
lives that he's taken
he struggles with his sense of worth
even when steve insists that he didn't
have a choice
bucky replies but i did it
not only did he take the lives of
innocents such as mr nakajima's son
but even people he knew like howard
stark howard worked closely with captain
america and the howling commandos during
world war ii
while never explicitly stated we can
gather from howard's search for caps
crash plane and tony stark mentioning
that his father spoke very highly of
steve
that he formed a personal connection
with cap in the commandos
tragically howard still recognized bucky
his last words being a bewildered
sergeant the emotional toll of being
forced to kill an old friend
weighs heavily on bucky made all the
worse by tony stark's anger and blame
justified as tony's feelings may be
bucky was not the one in control and
never would have chosen to kill howard
and maria stark of his own free will
i can't trust my own mind
perhaps even worse than his guilt is
bucky's very
real fear that he could be turned into a
mindless weapon once again
captain america civil war revealed that
bucky could be activated as the winter
soldier with a series of code words
while this control doesn't seem to have
as strong a hold over him without his
memory being regularly wiped it still
prevents
a huge danger feeling he can't trust his
own mind
bucky finds his salvation in wakanda
while the movies leave
off with bucky going into cryostasis and
pick back up again with him in fighting
shape for infinity war
what they skip over is the actual
process of his recovery
to find those answers we have to turn to
infinity war
prelude a tie-in comic that acts as a
prequel to the movie
putting bucky into cryostasis was
shuri's idea it turns out
t'challa's sister came up with a
possible solution for bucky's
brainwashing
that required him to enter cryostasis so
she could create a map of his mind
from there she could selectively remove
the programming that allows bucky to be
controlled with the trigger words
the process didn't come without risk
however there was a chance
shuri could accidentally reboot bucky's
brain and strip away more than hydra's
corruption
knowing this bucky still agreed to the
procedure and voluntarily allowed
himself to be placed in cryostasis
for what he hoped would be the last time
in his mind
eliminating the possibility that he
could be used as a weapon against
innocent people was worth the risk of
losing his entire identity
luckily thanks in no small part to
shuri's genius
it worked in episode 4 of falcon and the
winter soldier
we see bucky working with io one of the
dora melange
as a member of such an elite group of
warriors there was minimal risk to
anyone's safety if bucky's programming
triggered when io recites the winter
soldier's trigger words and bucky
remains in control
he is overcome with emotion crying tears
of joy and relief
bucky then spends the next year enjoying
some peace and calm in wakanda
working as a farmer and gaining the
nickname white wolf from the locals
despite everything he's been through
when t'challa comes to him with a new
vibranium arm bucky doesn't hesitate to
join the fight
to defend earth in avengers infinity war
where's the fight his recovery continues
after the events of avengers endgame
when he returns in the blip he attends
therapy sessions as a condition of the
us government's pardoning of his crimes
and works on making amends for
everything
hydra forced him to do he still
struggles with his trauma
suffering symptoms of ptsd but he's
certainly in a much better place than he
used to be
despite bucky's dark past his true
nature as a loyal
dedicated friend and selfless hero have
shone through
bucky's hiding place and civil war was
likely chosen because sebastian stan
himself was born in romania and speaks
the language
he moved to vienna shortly before the
collapse of the soviet union
later coming to america and pursuing a
career in acting